with people spending more time at home a
lot of people are doing
family game night so how about taking
family game night on the road
jc is live in chinatown at game nest
arcade
where jc i understand there's something
for everybody there
kendall there truly is and i want you to
meet abraham he is the owner
abraham so tell everyone what makes the
game that's different than the other
arcades
game this is real different because we
do pay by the hour so basically every
game you see in here
is on free play so there's no tokens no
cards perfect for every family every
size and date night when you slide over
here lance let's get a shot of this game
what game we're looking at right here
right now we're looking at my my the
rhythm game it's the only one in america
right now
and he's playing a doubles game it's a
very difficult rhythm game but a lot of
fun and the beat just keeps going and so
fast
this is he is non-stop he is non-stop
and of course you have a colbit protocol
in place you have all the sanitation
procedures
absolutely now slide over here this game
here is a drum game look at this
they didn't have this in the arcade back
in the 80s what's this one so this is a
game called taiko
taiko drum game it's based on the old
school japanese
uh chinese drum game basically where you
hit in the middle
and that's one strike and then on the
outside is a different kind of strike
and it shows you a rhythm of it
of every time you hit the drum on the
inside and on the outside these games
you're getting a workout
this is kind of my speed over here we
got about one minute i love this the
football toss
you know i played high school football
watch this ready
i saw this when i walked in we have arm
wrestling over the top absolutely so
what you're gonna do right here is
you're gonna
you're gonna pick your character we're
gonna test your strength in this one
with the biggest baddest person that you
can here we go down here this is so cool
this arcade is unbelievable and uh
30 seconds it's a big challenge here we
go can i can i take down this guy ready
no come on oh
it doesn't matter we'll do it we'll do
it together
come on and look at this
this is non-stop arcade action this year
is the 25th anniversary
of pokemon and you guys have a really
cool pokemon arcade game that we're
going to showcase in the four o'clock
hour
we got pikachu give me some kind of
dance pikachu
break it down this is unbelievable
abraham thank you so much
we'll have more coming up in the four
o'clock hour we'll send it back to you
guys in the studio
i gotta work on that arm wrestling i
really do jc my money was on you
i lost rocky had it right all right
we'll see you buddy
yeah over